hi
welcome to getting started with anthos
my name is bradley wong and i'm a
product manager at google cloud
and my name is aurelie fonteny and i'm a
product manager for antos
so today the agenda we're going to go
through
is we're going to start with an
introduction of what anthos is
we're going to go through some of the
use cases that our customers have seen
in the last 12 months of using anthus
and then we're going to go through uh
some suggestions on how to get started
with bandos
so what is anthos so
anthis has been around for more than 12
months now
in the in the open so a lot of customers
have asked us well
you know what is anthos is it gke
on-prem
is it gke is it a container as a service
platform
is it a platform as a service is it just
a bunch of open source tools
is a bundle of different tools that
google's offering
or is it all of the above
well probably a good way to start with a
description
is to actually start with a statement
that describes what anders is
now this is not all the different use
cases that anthes can provide but it
certainly is a core set
of how we think about adverse so
anthos is a managed platform for
enterprises that want faster
modernization and greater consistency in
a multi
and hybrid cloud world that's a lot of
words so let's break that down a little
bit
first manage platform what do we mean by
that
well first of all the platform
could be consumed or subscribed to
our customers can consume it as they
want as they need as their
requirements grow or they can also
purchase an upfront subscription to
offset any of the usage charges as well
next a managed platform is also
something that
takes away the toil of actually managing
it yourself
so in that sense google actually manages
that for you
so what we provide is the capability for
you to incrementally
upgrade the capabilities of the platform
as you deem
necessary and any updates to
versions to fix vulnerabilities to fix
bugs or add new features
is also managed by google as well
so next what do we mean by application
platform
in this sense an application platform
provides
something that can actually host the
applications of your choice
be they container based applications
or they can also be traditional
applications
our application platform is based on
completely open source projects
for example kubernetes sdo
k-native techton to name a few
now the platform is also designed for
enterprises in mind
that have large complex needs
it could be security requirements
operational requirements
governance requirements there's many
many requirements that our enterprises
need to cater for and anthos provides
all those enterprises with the
capability to manage
all those needs be they large or small
next our customers also want the ability
to
have access to faster modernization
and with anthos we provide tooling to
help our customers
to have no touch migrations from
traditional workloads into modern
workloads
and not just the actual applications
themselves but also
the platform and we provide tools
to help our customers modernize the way
they even manage the platform itself
next anthos provides greater consistency
now it's very common that across our
enterprise customers
that they may deploy anthos in not just
a single
deployment option like in gcp but may
want to deploy this across
hybrid environments as well as
multi-cloud environments
so in that sense the importance to have
a single pane of glass and a single
definition
of how they want security policies
or even just general configurations need
to be kept in sync across
all those environments and andos
provides
methods to achieve that
finally anthos is a multi-cloud and
hybrid cloud
platform it's completely software-based
which means
it runs inside on-premises data centers
inside gcp and also in other clouds
now anthos didn't happen overnight
it is actually a combination of decades
worth of work from google
now there's no secret that google has
been using containers
for many many years and even today
google still leverages the father of
kubernetes which is something internally
we call borg
now in the early or mid 2010s
so in the 2013-2014 time frame
google open sourced a project called
kubernetes to the world
which had a lot of the building blocks
stemming from
our experiences of operating container
environments at scale
kubernetes is now one of the most
successful open source projects
in the industry now
we saw that kubernetes although was very
powerful
it was actually quite complex to use
so we released in 2015
something we call gke which allowed our
customers
to not have to think about how to
install and manage kubernetes we
as google manage it for you and gke
is that vehicle today on a daily basis
we see billions of containers deployed
onto gke by customers all around the
world
so then naturally in 2018 because
of the demand to use gke
we saw that there was also an increased
demand to use gke
not just inside google cloud's
environment but also
in all other environments as well
we started with gk on-prem in 2018
and now with and we expanded
to multiple different environments so in
2019
at next anthos was announced by ceo
sunda pichai to be generally available
we are now 12 months into
the general availability of anthis and
this
is where anthon sits today
anthos is now able to be deployed across
multiple different environments whether
it's on-premises data centers
ed computing environments google cloud
other clouds and also other kubernetes
clusters
it also provides multiple different
services on top
whether it's cluster management service
management
providing developers with more agility
through serverless and app develop
development frameworks manage operations
as well as policy and configuration
management
what this translates to concretely for
the different components and deployment
options of bantus is this
we now have multiple different
deployment options
so on-prem bare metal
which is coming into preview this this
quarter on gcp
we recently made available uh anderson
aws
by the end of this year we also have
azure vms
becoming available and we also just
announced the general availability of
anthony's attached clusters to
allow our customers to deploy anthos on
other kubernetes environments
essentially bringing your own kubernetes
environment to anthus
now anthus then provides a single pane
of glass to manage all of those
environments but on top of that provides
opinionated
components to enable additional services
gke for container management and the
service
mesh to manage your service mesh
deployments powered by istio
cloud run to provide a serverless
framework
cloud code to provide
ide enabled development environments
cloud logging and cloud monitoring to
provide operational visibility across
all those deployment options whether
it's for the platform itself
or for the applications as well as
anthis config
management which provides consistency of
deploying
policies and configurations across all
those environments
so now let's take a moment on
looking at what some of our customers
are using anthes for
so let's have a look at some of the use
cases that anthos has been has enabled
over the past 12 months
the first one that we find most commonly
is customers who want to
migrate and modernize their application
stacks
many of these customers really want to
enable their developers to move faster
and their reliance on legacy
applications and their stacks have been
an impedance to be able to offer better
business agility
so when the promise of containers has
come up
uh that was obviously a very appealing
path to choose but it was very difficult
for our customers to do that without a
lot of refactoring
anthus provides our customers the
tooling and the capabilities to help
them
migrate now from legacy applications
into more modern
container-based environments with
limited refactoring
we also have customers who are already
experts at using containers
kubernetes and some of them are already
gke customers
but many of them have also on-premises
requirements because they can't move
their workloads into cloud today
so many of them are looking at anthos to
actually
be that next generation uh container
environment or container platform
um variety of reasons why they they're
looking at that
but the ease of use the consistency uh
the cost of flexibility
all those come to head when they're
evaluating some of the new platforms
that they want to invest in and anthos
has time and time again been a platform
of choice for a lot of our customers who
are coming
from some existing kubernetes
environments
we also have a lot of customers who are
coming from interesting
places such as in the retail space or in
a telco space
who really want to use anthos as a means
to deploy
clusters and platforms in places where
you might not expect them to exist
whether they are inside retail stores or
locations inside ballparks
or next to telco 5g towers
a lot of our customers really want to
move
analytic applications closer and closer
to those environments to get closer to
their customers
and finally we have a lot of customers
who really
value the benefits of some of the
intelligent
gcp services that are offered
now some of them may not have the
ability
to move those workloads into a cloud
environment yet
for regulatory or compliance reasons
so rather than asking our customers to
move their data
into gcp today what we are doing
is moving the intelligent services like
ai and ml services
into their on-premises environments and
and this provides them the ability to do
that
so also consistently across all of those
different use cases we have customers
who not just want to modernize the
application stacks but also want to
monetize
how they are doing operations so get ops
is a common theme across most of the
customers
using git based mechanism software
delivery
continuous delivery type of methods to
not just
provide continuous deployments of their
applications
into dev staging production but also to
do that
for their infrastructure definitions as
well so
leveraging git controls to describe
their configurations for the platform
allows them to mutate modify
check in check out configurations and be
able to deploy
different versions of their application
stack at scale
in light of that many other customers
then will take that advantage
and be able to stamp out
verified and certified versions of the
configurations
that they deem as important for
different security zones
inside those environments some of them
may have small stringent security
settings in say for example production
or staging
but less stringent security environments
for development and testing
with the get ops model and with
configures data
it's possible to ensure versioning and
it's possible to ensure the
correct security postures have been
rolled out with the right configurations
across
all these different environments
finally many of our customers are also
isvs who want to have
the most frictionless way to roll out
their software platform
without having to build a entirely new
infrastructure or application stack
themselves so
anthos offers a lot of our isv partners
the ability to take their software
platform
and to deliver a software as a service a
sas
solution for a lot of those
solutions as well so
with that i'm now going to hand over to
my colleague
orilli who's going to walk you through
how to get started with anthos
thank you brad so i will now walk you
through the specifics
on how to get started so the first thing
is you want to learn more about amp
tools so you can go and start with the
antlers documentation
and tools specific quick labs and
coursera training
then the next step after that is to try
hand tools
in your environment so for entels
running on gcp
we currently have a limited time
promotion
where antos usage is free up to a limit
for testing purposes
and we will introduce a self-service
trial for 30 days
once the promotion runs out
you may also contact sales if you want
to do your own hybrid
and multi-cloud proof of concept
once you're ready to buy hand tools you
have two options
you can either pay as you go and this is
a default option
or you can contact sales to subscribe to
a committed usage
at a preferential price point
now if you want to start with xentos in
your environment
we have a tutorial that's available to
explore entels
running on gcp there are two parts to it
the first one is a pre-packaged ample
sample environment
that includes a cluster and those
features
and an online store application
we refer to it as the android sample
deployment
the other part is a companion tutorial
and it helps you experience and tools
through core tasks
and so that's what i'm going to demo
next in the cloud console
so for this demo i've created
a new project i have navigated to the
antos dashboard
and i've enabled anthos
so as a first time user i'm presented
with various
options to get started
the first one is to launch the into
simple deployment
so i'm going to go ahead and click it
and launch it
so there are a few configuration options
i'm gonna go and use the default values
now
you need to check the box here that
ensures that you meet
all the prerequisites uh to deploy the
handle sample
so what that means is you need
a new project under relevant permissions
and you can see more details at this
it's going to the tutorial and in there
you can also find a script that checks
that your project
meets all the prerequisites so i'm going
to copy it
go back to the cloud console activate
the cloud share
and run it so it's checking that i have
the right permissions that
we don't have any aug policies that the
right apis are enabled
and that the intel sample deployment has
not been previously deployed
so great i've passed the prerequisites
and i can deploy the end of sample
so from there it's going to take about
10 minutes for everything to be deployed
configured and running
meanwhile you can take a look at the
antlers tutorial
and from there you can follow the guided
experience
now i already have a separate project
that has been pre-provisioned so i can
start
exploring antos so let's go
to the antlers dashboard to explore
the resources that we've been creating
with the anti-sample deployment
in particular the intel sample
deployment has created
a cluster with enters
and an application so you can see here
i'm in the dashboard i have 11 services
and i have one cluster so i'm going to
view the clusters
i can see it's 6vcpu
and i can get more details in gke
and from there i can navigate to
clusters workloads and in my case i'm
interested in going to
services and ingress
so that i can check the sto ingress
gateway service
because this is a service that's hosting
the endpoints
for the sample applications front end
so i'm going to go to it
and you can see the sample application
that's been deployed it's called
the online boutique and you can
explore it from there i'm going to add
it to
a shopping cart you can place another
so now we can take a look at the
internals
for this sample application by going
back to the amp tools dashboard
and looking at android service mesh so
i'm going to view the service mesh
so you can see here i have a table view
of the key services in the application
and associated metrics
i can also take a look at the topology
view
for workloads and services so for
instance here i have a shopping cart
service
you can see the inbound connection
outbound connections
and traffic going through it
and you can get more details so
i'm going to go to the service dashboard
for the shopping cart service
we can see more telemetry details for
instance the
latency 50th percentile is 54
millisecond
and the service status here is none
because there are no slo created for
this service so
i'm going to create a service level
objective
i'll use latency
as our indicator of performance
i'll choose a very low latency threshold
so we can see the effect
of going past our error budget
for calendar day at
90 compliance
so let's submit it
as you can see here we are past our
error budget
and you can get more details so now we
could
also set alert policies to get
notification
so in the interest of time we won't go
through
all the tasks in the explorators
tutorial
now you can go through it on your own
and you can see that we've gone through
the first four tasks and the next one
is to apply an encryption policy
using antlers configuration management
so check out the antlers tutorial
and try it on your own
so this concludes our demo and
presentation
and we want to leave you with key
takeaways
so first air tools is the hybrid and
multi-cloud platform
for application modernization
second it helps you productionize your
modern application environment
based on the common set of tools such as
policies
and service observability across
environments
then andos is completely software based
it is based on open source and so it
removes any type of locking
bit on the environment or the api being
used
and last you can try enters today
by taking advantage of trial options and
by exploring anthos
with the tutorial so here are the
related sessions
where you can get more details on hand
tools
if you have any follow-up questions
please go ahead
and refer to the dory for this session
you